so extraction a movie about a mercenary
being hired to save a kid from harm my
elevator pitch for the movie would
basically be a combination of John wick
and Terminator 2 but worse the main
reason why I think it's worse it's just
how bland the whole movie is there are a
few reasons why and the first one is the
characters we have Tyler who has a
character depth of a 1 foot kiddie pool
he's basically just a depressed
mercenary and all that early is to him
is that he lost his kid they keep
bashing that fact into your skull
through t'see flashbacks throughout the
whole movie and it comes off as very
annoying
you gotta leave the kid behind Tyler Joe
Russo the writer is just spoon feeding
you this information in an attempt to
legitimize the relationship between
Tyler and Rizzo it isn't believable that
Tyler wants to throw everything away for
this kid he just meant because he lost a
kid in the past the only reason for the
audience to get behind Tyler is because
he wants to do good and save the kid
which is just blame motivation is blind
motivation because he hasn't really
gotten to know the kid so why does he
want to sacrifice everything to save him
so that brings us to the topic of reaso
he's completely two-dimensional and
there isn't a reason why Tyler likes him
besides the fact that he's a kid
his only character trade is playing the
piano so the connection between the two
characters is flimsy at best we don't be
on a father he took an island
he thinks of me the same way you do more
like a thing than a bosom they also
don't really bond in the movie and there
is never a moment of connection between
the two characters like in Terminator 2
for example the only point of connection
between the two characters that was
meaningful came in at the 1 hour and 8
minute mark but by this point it's
already too late because the movie is
practically almost over and we've
already gone through most of their
adventure also this is pretty crappy
bonding on top of the whole piano thing
it wasn't even there are you dude that
will you all Tyler really does is tell
reaso about how he lost his kid which is
just bashing that plot thread into your
skull for the millionth time in general
since these characters are bland I
didn't have emotional stakes in the
action because of my detachment with the
characters the action because of that
becomes a spectacle and there wasn't
that much of a story to keep me
interested any attempt out a story like
the drug cartel stuff just came off as
stereotypical and boring also the
villain Tintin a foreign personality
whatsoever he could have literally been
taken out a terminator and I wouldn't
even know he's just a drone that is
trying to kill Tyler and there's not
much else to it
so yeah I don't see how anyone can get
behind these characters the only reason
why this somewhat works is because he's
Chris Hemsworth and it's hard to hate
him so going back to the action I
thought it was pretty entertaining and
that's really the only draw for the
movie but for me there is one flaw about
the action besides that Genki one shot
sequence so the flaw of the action is
that there isn't in a variety for most
of the movie Chris Hemsworth runs around
with an assault rifle just gunning
people down to degree this is pretty
cool but if you don't change that method
of carrying out action it quickly starts
to deteriorate in the final action
sequence this was the primary method of
carrying on action and just became very
dull and repetitive also since this is
the last action sequence this is the
final impression the movie makes on you
so to me since I had this dull
repetitive final impression and maybe
not like the movie as much also the
action sequence was 30 minutes so they
desperately needed more variety it
really starts to feel like a mission out
of Call of Duty to a certain point
like chris hemsworth is just running
through a linear set gunning down random
baddies tell me that's not different
this is basically how it's worse than
John wick to me like look at this
choreography and now look at this what
is much more clever and one isn't don't
get me wrong the action is still good
the gunplay just gets too repetitive by
the end of the movie in comparison the
first action scene was genuinely great
because I had a lot of variety it the
movie resumed to have this level of
creativity in action then it would feel
more fresh and fun another small point
as to how the movie is bland is the look
at the movie I don't know why people in
Hollywood think that Bangladesh is
yellow it's as if I'm watching a movie
in a yellow [ __ ] of sunglasses to me it
just looks visually uninteresting and
it's kind of immersion breaking because
of how unnatural it looks having this
dull look in your film kind of just puts
a bland aura over the whole movie but
yeah these are just some of the reasons
why I didn't like the movie I think it's
pretty overrated given it's getting
relatively good reviews the action can
be enjoyable but it's just an insult to
me just how bland everything comes off
and how little the effort was put into
the writing especially since Joe Russo
was a director on Avengers so in that
sense I gave it a 2 out of 5 on
letterboxed so yeah this was my first
video review so thank you guys for
watching the whole thing I will
occasionally do more reviews on this
channel since I want to do more creative
content I also have the link to letter
box in the description if you guys are
interested hopefully you guys enjoyed
the video and have a nice day